hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video my name is flipping old school
for those who don't know me um mostly do
at this point today I'm going to be
going over a brand new tool that
introduced to me recently and that is GE
tracker now it's kind of an alternative
to RS buddy and what I mean alternative
it is a brand new uh service but it is
quite a bit better uh in quite a few
different ways it has a bunch more
information than either the other
exchange websites offer and while some
of it is uh premium service most of the
important features are still free um
free free to use however many times you
want and um yeah let's jump into it and
we'll see what it offers okay so to
start off we are going to break down uh
clearly what you going to get for free
and what you're going to get for the
premium service uh which is two quid
quid a month but um yeah for free you
are going to get uh three favorite items
which I'll show you in a minute access
to the item pricing graph as well as the
Buy sell quantities uh but you will get
a little bit more information than the
regular RS buddy graph access to the
basic profit
tracker uh which is a kind of cool tool
to track your profits um you're going to
get some suggested suggested flips um so
you're going to get five of these in
every 10 minutes now these are nice but
are not in any way required to take full
advantage of this tool it's going to be
suggesting some of the best flips based
on whatever algorithm they're using um a
really cool one is actually access to
public merchanting logs now these are
logs of people that they made public uh
so not everyone's log is made public
it's only if you choose it to so there's
some really great information there you
can see what people are flipping um but
of course you want to keep yours hidden
it won't be showed by default at all and
you have access to another high volume
items tab uh which going to show you
some suggested flips uh in a more high
volume category and yeah that's where're
it for free uh for premium some of the
major things you're going to get is
you're going to get 50 suggested
profitable items uh which is quite
useful um a couple more categories for
looking for flips which going to be
recently added to the
game um and GE limits as well as the
most profitable
items and another cool feature you can
do is you can import uh your OS buddy
log so it'll automatically track what
items you're flipping what profits
you're getting uh another important
feature of Premium is that you have
access to a bunch of different um money
making methods that are automatically
calculated by the system so stuff like
uh High Al and guide what would be best
high Al uh selling to the camia store as
well as herblore decanting potions I
mean there's loads of stuff um and we'll
jump into that in a second here and yeah
so that's a run of the the features um
most of the important ones are included
in the free package so you don't need to
buy anything as well as you will get to
try the premium out for two days uh when
you make your account so you can kind of
decide what you want to do from there
and yeah let's jump into some of the
features okay so you can see we're in GE
tracker and I'm going to go over the
free tools again to show you exactly
what you're going to get um so to start
off you obviously have access to the
Search tool um so let's just pop an item
in here let's go with the Bandos
godsword and it'll pop up auto fill
pretty nice and then you're going to get
a bunch of information here um some of
which is premium but most of is is free
um so to start off here uh we have a
picture which is nice and it's going to
show you a quick guide on what the
approximate profit is on the item uh
which is based on the last half an hour
which is a bit quicker than RS buudy and
one of the features I really like here
is you can actually go back more than a
month more than a quarter you can go
back a
year uh which isn't offered by our budy
so that's pretty nice you can see the
track the profits over the last year and
um another cool thing about this is you
can see these letterings here uh these
are updates are podcasts or things that
were changed that could affect the
pricing of the item so you noticed that
the last couple weeks uh the Bandos
Squad sort rose up and you can kind of
look at so hardcore Iron Man mode was
announced then uh here's the raid
rewards uh so you can kind of piece
together um what may have caused that
Spike with these little key markers here
which is pretty awesome uh below you're
going to have access to um the quantity
how much is bought and sold and um the
rest is going to be premium features um
which I'll explain in a minute here but
this is just for what's offered for
free and yeah so we have the Bandos
godsword now one other thing that's
offered for free is you can add them to
your favorite items which you'll do by
hitting the star here I can have three
favorite items as a free member and um
so yeah once you have it favored you'll
come over here to your favorite items
Tab and this is pretty useful for items
you do a lot it's going to quickly show
you all the items that you favored you
can sort by the current price uh how
much profit you're get looking to get
your recover from um sorry return on
investment and um a quick rundown of how
many are bought and sold an hour which
is quite useful to quickly look at how
much an item is actually selling um
it'll also show you the GE limits if
it's been tracked so far I believe this
is a premium feature however U but you
can always find them yourself um but it
is very nice to have them right here and
uh yeah that's for the favorite items
now I think you actually have access to
this high volume tab as well uh which
will show you some suggested items that
are high volume uh so you can see here
the dragon darts um seem to have 165 GP
margin on them uh it shows you the
buying quantity which is really kind of
what you're looking for here you're
going to want to double check um the the
margin here and I'm pretty sure it even
says on the website to do it um but
again this is just a rough indicator of
how the item is doing and um what kind
of profit You' look to
get and the last feature that is really
awesome that's available to free members
is um the public merchanting logs that I
mentioned earlier so you can see here
under the Lether board uh the
merchanting logs now these are ones
people purposely made public um they had
little goals which is awesome so this
guy here um let's good with this one
looking to get one bill and he's logged
75 mil so far so let's just have a quick
look at his merchanting log um so you
can see these are Auto verified so I
believe what is happening is they are
pulling it right from his RS buddy
account um but I'm not 100% sure on that
but anyway you can see a ton of
different items that this person has
flipped um their approximate profits you
can see right here how much they've been
in
total um I think this might be in the
week or something um and yeah it's just
a really awesome feature get a ton of
ideas for what you're going to flip and
that is pretty much what's available to
free load more than our RS buddy and
yeah we'll go over the uh paid features
in a moment here okay so next up I'm
going to show you everything that's
accessible to premium members and why
you might want to consider upgrading at
some point I mean it's only 2 pounds a
month so it's not like a ton of money um
and while you do get most of the
information from the freeze tool it is a
quite a lot of awesome features that
you're going to get with the premium
membership um but either way let's have
a quick look so to start off you're
going to get unlimited favorite items so
if we go over here to the favorite item
tab I mean only have six right now but
you can have a as many as you want and
while three is useful in the beginning
once you have more items you're flipping
it is quite nice just to be able to hit
a quick rundown of what is at the top at
that current time I save 100 items here
you just hit what's giving you the best
profit and you can kind of sort through
the top five or 10 or whatever you want
to um yeah so that's for the favorite
items now for the uh information screen
we'll quickly go in here to The Archers
ring um so obviously you're going to get
everything the free member has but
you're going to get couple extras and
that is going to be uh the day graph so
it's going to show you uh the last half
an hour of the item which is the most
current information I've ever found as
so we're at
3.52k or 3 whatever mil and uh another
awesome feature is the split graph now
this is probably one of my favorite it's
going to show you the difference between
the buy and sell price at that time uh
where regularly you're just going to get
the price uh but the split graph feature
is going to show you what it was sold
for and what it was bought for so it's
giving you the margins in a historical
fashion which is really
awesome another really cool feature I
haven't actually tried yet is the price
alert feature it can send you an a text
message or an email when something is
above or below a current price oh which
is awesome I mean I haven't actually
tried it yet and I'm sure you don't want
to set too many of these or might get a
little annoying but for major things
you're flipping that's just quite a
sweet feature and yeah that's what
you're going to get for the uh item
information screen and moving on to
another feature is going to be the
profit tracker
and this is uh accessed to begin with
through this screen here so say I want
to flip the Archer ring um I'm going to
put an offer in here so this is the
profit track U the tracker sorry um so
you're going to put it in for let's
say
3080 K or 3.1 mil pretty much put in
some zeros there think that's right and
we can buy eight of
them and we'll hit buy so that's going
to add it to our tracker and obviously
at that point you put it into your ran
exchange interface and yeah so we'll
head over here to the profit tracker
let's just at this side and go to active
transactions so it's going to give you a
really awesome little kind of uh bar
graph not bar graph but a little table
here showing you active offers completed
offers active sales and completed
transactions it's quite user friendly
and pretty easy to understand uh so we
have the active offer here so once it's
completed uh we'll just move it over
here and uh so next we're going to put
it in for a sell price so we'll move it
over to the active sales so say we're
selling it for
3200 pretty good margin on it right
now and hit okay and it's going to give
you a little rundown of how much you're
getting per ring how much you're getting
in total it's just really awesome really
easy to
visualize and then once it's finally
sold you're just going to move it over
to your completed transactions and it's
gonna add it to your log and your log is
going to show you how much money you've
made uh through the website now the
amount of money you've made is publicly
available the items you've used is not
unless you make it that
way and then we'll just head over here
to the dashboard I
believe 's
see and that will go to the profile here
and you can see my uh merchanting graph
it's going to show you the recent
transactions and you can make it public
if you want I show you the dates and
everything uh let see if we can get
dashboard now and it's going to show you
my um kind of quick overview I have four
total
transactions most profitable item is
1.84 MIL I'm doing The Archers ring most
frequently and yeah it's just a really
awesome tool very userfriendly and I
can't really stress enough how awesome
it is uh whether using the free tool or
the paid tool and how could I almost
forget the most important feature a lot
of you guys are probably looking for is
the moneymaking tab now this is a
premium feature only and it's going to
show you a bunch of different ways to
make money and the most current at that
so let's just have a quick look at a
couple of them so the high alchemy One
it's pretty useful if you're going to be
training magic it's going to show you
some items offers you can put in they'll
actually profit you when you Al them
this isn't a great Money Maker but it's
good for training magic and just kind of
interesting uh decanting potions that's
something I've shown you guys a lot uh
but you can quickly see what potions are
profitable um some interesting things
I've never really done before like
barrows repair so You' buy the broken
barrows item and repair it and then sell
it I'm actually interested in trying
that um Tanny leather it's a common one
but also is going to give you what the
most profitable leather is at the time
uh plank making um the CR store I mean
there's tons of stuff there there's a
couple more I won't go through all of
them but those are the moneymaking
methods it is definitely worth uh the
premium membership I've made quite a bit
just using these already and yeah that
is all the premium features and that
about wraps us up guys so I hope you
enjoyed the video if you want to go try
G tracker a link will be in the
description I would highly recommend it
whether you're going to go with a free
membership which is totally fine there's
tons of awesome information there or if
you want to pay the two bucks or two
quid whatever uh to get some of this
premium information um it's up to you
but either way I think you can take
advantage of this uh new tool and if
you're new to my channel um toss the
video like uh see Subs subcribed because
I would like to make more videos on G
tracker and uh that way you'll know when
they released all right guys hope you
enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]